[Musique]
imaginons un gâteau au sucre avec 3
cerise sur le gâteau alice bob charlie
et eve veulent chacun une part mais
alice bob et charly sont au régime
strict et ils ne veulent donc pas
toucher un gâteau si sucre et eve
elle est juste mortes de faim et les
cerises représente une quantité de
nourriture négligeable selon elle
qu'est ce que serait un partage juste du
gâteau et des cerises entre alice bob
charlie et eve
alors je parlais que vous hésitez entre
trois possibilités répond ça a coupé le
gâteau en quatre parts égales et donner
à chacun trois quarts de cerise et
concevez donné le gâteau avait une
cerise à chacun des autres et réponse
dès la réponse t bon ok on a oublié à
rester très clairement à la réponse a
est juste elle est équitable c'est la
solution égalitaire tout le monde a le
même sort mais quand même on sent que
c'est pas optimale alice bob et charlie
risque de jeter leur part de gâteau à la
poubelle et elle sera tout triste voir
que trois quarts de gâteaux auront été
gâchée il reste alors la réponse b qu'en
pensez vous serait-il juste de donner
tout le gâteau à eve est une cerise à
chacun des autres je vous invite à
écrire baitieri wimbée tir et non dans
les commentaires il mettait bien en
tirer entre le béa et la réponse pour
que je puisse ensuite faire contrôler
pour compter vos réponses oui parce
qu'albert fois que je vous ai demandé de
mettre des trucs dans les commentaires
je suis bien galéré pour compter vos
réponses elle jouait 53 secondes alors à
l'école on vous a peut-être appris que
faire des maths c'est faire des calculs
ça c'est complètement faux c'est
complètement faux on a déjà des
calculatrices pour faire des calculs
alors si vous êtes allé assez loin dans
les maths ou vous a sans doute appris
que les maths c'est plutôt en fait
prouvé des théorèmes dans ça c'est pas
faux mais pour moi le plus intéressant
en maths c'est surtout identifier les
concepts intéressants c'est trouver les
bonnes définition celle qui permettront
de voir les choses sous un nouvel angle
est ce que je vous propose aujourd'hui
c'est une quête d'une définition
pertinente de ce que pourrait être la
justesse du taux disons l'équité d'un
partage d'un gâteau sucré avec 3 cerise
alors la première définition de l'équité
on l'a déjà vu c'est l'égalitarisme
aussi appelé partage exact un partage et
égalitaire si tout bêtement toutes les
parts sont égales c'est un peu la
définition la plus stricte de l'équité
et comme on l'a vu
arrêt un peu restrictive et risque de
conduire du gâchis donc essayons d'être
plus malin notre remarque que l'on peut
faire c'est que sève a eu 100 % de ce
qu'elle aurait pu aspirer à contrario à
lisbonne et charlie n'ont qu'une cerise
sur trois possibles et du coup ils ont
chacun 33% de ceux qu'ils auraient pu
espérer
et oui comme le gâteau n'a aucune valeur
pour eux pour eux tout était comme s'il
n'y avait que trois cerise à se partager
et une série sur trois bassins et 33%
mais du coup on est tenté de dire que le
partage n'est pas équitable puisque a eu
100 % de ce qu'elle aurait pu avoir
alors que les autres n'ont eu que 33 %
savent où couvent où est-ce qu'il ya
quelque chose qui cloche avec cette
conclusion
n'hésitez pas à mettre pause pour y
réfléchir 30 secondes ok le truc étrange
c'est qu'avec cette équité par
pourcentage des possibles on peut rendre
le partage équitable avec un
raisonnement bizarroïdes
en effet imaginons qu'au lieu d'un
gâteau sucrier maintenant trois gâteaux
au sucre et qu'on décide de jeter deux
décades au sucre à la poubelle on se
retrouve avec un gâteau et 3 cerise que
l'on peut réaffecter exactement comme
précédemment
sauf que cette fois comme les autres eve
n'aura eu que 33 % de l'ensemble des
possibles on conclut donc que se
partagent et équitable par pourcentage
des possibles alors que c'est exactement
le même partage que précédemment
voyez le problème les pourcentages qu'on
a calculé dépendent fortement de
l'ensemble des possibles et en
particulier des cas extrêmes qui
correspondent à tout à voir ou à ne rien
avoir et ça c'est pas génial parce que
du coup les cas extrêmes vont grandement
affecté la manière dont on pense le
problème
et oui au lieu de considérer que le
meilleur truc qui puisse arriver c'est à
voir tout le gâteau et 3 cerise on
pourrait en fait se dire que le meilleur
meilleur truc qui puisse arriver c'est
vraiment trouver mille euros sur la rue
ou encore je suis pas gagné au loto
changer ce que l'on considérait être le
meilleur est possible ou le pire des
possibles va complètement changer votre
jugement de ce qui est le pourcentage
des possibles en fait en pratique les
pires cas elle est meilleure qu'à sont
en fait des cas si improbable que l'on
peut douter de leur pertinence pour
juger du taux de satisfaction des uns et
des autres et donc pour juger de la
justesse qu'un partage comparer les
pourcentages de satisfaction des
différentes parties prenantes ne semble
pas franchement pertinent à l'équité du
partage mais en revanche ce que l'on
peut faire c'est con
paris les satisfactions des parties
prenantes par opposition au cas du
partage égalitaire et bien justement on
dit que le partage est
proportionnellement juste si chacun
finit avec une part qui considèrent
meilleure que celle qu'il aura eu dans
un partage égalitaire et dans notre cas
on a un partage proportionnellement
juste en effet sachant que le gâteau n'a
aucune valeur pour alice bob est charlie
en passant du partage et égalité arts au
partage de la réponse b pour ice bob et
charlie c'est surtout passer de trois
quarts de cerises à une cerise complète
disions donc tous trois gagné au change
de même elle est passée d'un quart de
gâteaux à tout un gâteau entier c'est
tout bénef tout le monde préfère donc se
partagent au partage égalitaire
le partage est donc proportionnellement
juste à j'aime bien cette définition
parce que c'est sans doute un peu comme
ça que l'on réfléchisse en pratique
comme l'écrit très bien david dans sa
série critères de cerveau on se compare
souvent à une référence et on se demande
si on s'en sort mieux que selon cette
référence
alors petite note historique aussi menti
qu'on parle de partage
proportionnellement juste parce que dans
un certain cadre mathématiques plus
restreint cette définition du partage
proportionnellement juste est
équivalente à dire que chacun des haines
invités à au moins un sur aisne du
gâteau pour lui et selon lui cependant à
mon sens il s'agit là d'un cadre c'est
difficile à justifier notamment parce
que les hypothèses sont assez fausse en
pratique mais aussi parce que tout ça
est intimement liée à la normalisation
par valeurs extrêmes dont j'ai déjà dit
qui a été assez critiquable elles vont
bien comprendre tout ça il faudrait que
je vous parle à nouveau des actions de
von magnet morgenstern et je préfère
vous renvoyer vers un article que j'ai
publié pour en savoir plus toujours est
il qu'une propriété remarquable du
partage proportionnellement juste c'est
sa stabilité par libéralisation du
marché
supposons que l'on impose initialement
un partage égalitaire et que l'on
autorise ensuite le libre échange alors
on s'attend à ce que eve partage
judicieusement ces miettes de ce risque
avec les parts de gâteaux des autres en
particulier s'attend à ce que dans ce
cadre libéraliste si on suppose que
personne ne peut forcer un autre à lui
donner une part autrement dit si on
suppose que tout échange de biens
requiert un consentement mutuel
alors tout échange qui aura lieu sera
forcément gagnant gagnant par rapport au
statu quo ainsi si on impose un partage
égalitaire qui soit dit en passant est
forcément proportionnellement juste et
si on autorise ensuite libre échange
en surveillant l'absence de raquette ou
de vol par chantage ou autre alors on
aboutira nécessairement un partage
proportionnellement juste alors le
partage proportionnellement juste c'est
cool mais ça correspond pas encore tout
à fait à l'intuition en tout cas pas à
mon intuition de ce qu'est un partage
juste
en effet considérant le cas où rêve à
tous le gâteau alice à 3/4 de cerises
bob à 3/4 de cerise et charlie à une
cerise et demi est ce que ce partage et
équitable et bien je vous laisse
vérifier qu'il s'agit d'un partage
proportionnellement juste sauf qu'on a
envie de dire qu'il n'est pas vraiment
justes notamment parce qu alice et bob
risque de se sentir lésé notamment par
rapport à la part qu'a reçue charlie
alice et bob risque d'être jaloux de
charlie vous voyez où est ce que j'ai
envie d'en venir ont dit tout simplement
que le partage que je viens de décrire
est avec jalousie mais ça c'est bien sûr
par opposition à des partages plus juste
qui serait sans jalousie et ça a
formellement ça donne quoi
allez c'est pas une question rhétorique
je vous invite vraiment et y réfléchir
et à déterminer par vous même une
définition mathématiques de ce qu'est un
partage sans jalousie
n'hésitez pas à mettre pause et bien un
partage sans jalousie c'est tout
simplement un partage dans lequel chacun
préfère sa part à n'importe quel autre
part si vous l'aviez trouver
félicitations vous venez de faire l'un
des trucs les plus cools en
mathématiques
vous venez de trouver une définition
rigoureuse et pertinente à un concept
fondamental
je suis sérieux le concept de partage
sans jalousie est l'une des meilleures
formalisation mathématiques de ce que
pourrait être un partage juste
je pense enfin un appartement communauté
mathématique il travaille sur cette
question aussi appuyé contre tout ça au
partage de la réponse b dans ce cas
alice a aussi bien que bob et que
charlie puisque chacun a une cerise et
elle préfère sa part à l'ats par dave
puisqu'elle n'a même pas de cerises
alice ne peut donc être jalouse de
personnes
elle préfère sa part à n'importe quel
autre part de même bob et charlie ne
sont jaloux de personnes
quant à m bah il en est quasiment à
plaindre les autres qui m'aiment pas pu
goûter le gâteau sucre n'est clairement
pas jalouse elle non plus la réponse b
était bien un partage sans jalousie
quand même au moins trois limites ou
concept de partage sans jalousie le
premier c'est que c'est un concept assez
binaire juste ou pas juste et ça on aime
pas trop parce que c'est pas très bon
pour faire de l'optimisation ensuite en
particulier qu'est ce qu'on fait il
n'existe aucun partage sans jalousie
pardon s'il y avait deux cerises et
qu'il était interdit de couper les
cerises
alors pour résoudre un peu ce problème
une partie de ma thèse a justement
consisté à proposer une définition d'une
mesure de la quantité de jalousie le
second problème c'est que bien souvent
quand on doit se partager un gâteau le
gâteau n'est pas tombée du ciel
en général il a fallu bosser pour avoir
le gâteau et tout le monde n'a pas
forcément autant bossé
autrement dit en pratique on a envie de
rajouter une dimension méritocratique
mais comment faire bien on y reviendra
dans une future vidéo
enfin une troisième et dernière limite
c'est qu' il peut y avoir pas mal de cas
où les parts ne sont pas
interchangeables
c'est le cas par exemple si au lieu de
parts de gâteau on avait en fait une
affectation de postes dans l'armée par
exemple et qu'il fallait certaines
aptitudes physiques pour pouvoir avoir
certaines affectations ce moment là il
peut être impossible d'échanger les
postes de deux personnes parce qu'un des
postes requièrent une aptitude que
l'autre individu n'a pas forcément
est ce que c'est encore un sens de
parler de partage sans jalousie dans ce
cas a priori non en tout cas le concept
semble pas tout à fait bien adapté mais
du coup comment décrire mathématiquement
une version satisfaisante de l'équité
dans ce cas là par contre j'ai pas trop
de réponses intelligentes à vous donner
je pense qu'on peut considérer que c'est
encore une question ouverte à
l'interface entre les mathématiques la
philosophie l'éthique tout ce que vous
alors toutes ces questions peuvent vous
sembler être un pur effort intellectuel
mais à l'heure où de plus en plus de
décisions sont prises par des
algorithmes
il me semble qu'il est plus important
que jamais que de forcer ses algorithmes
à faire preuve d'équité et ceci ne
pourra pas se faire tant que l'on n'aura
pas compris nous mêmes ce qu'elle ait
quitté et tant que l'on n'aura pas su
mathématisée de manière suffisamment
satisfaisantes
ce concept finalement si ambigu la
dernière fois on a parlé du mécanisme
bcg et redit qu'il était socialement
optimale et un script est écrit que les
demandes en quoi le mécanisme vcg et
socialement optima qu'est ce que l'on
entend vraiment parts sociales non
optimale et bien du canon cadre de cette
maudite
sur la seconde entend par socialement
optimale c'est prendre une décision pour
tout le monde une décision collective
qui a la plus grande valeur
quand on some les valeurs que les
différentes parties prenantes attribue à
la décision finale
alors c'est bien joli ce que je viens
dire là mais en fait ça pose tout plein
de problèmes et vous avez été très très
bon pour détecter beaucoup beaucoup de
problèmes qu'il ya avec le mécanisme bcg
le mécanisme vcc n'est absolument pas
une réponse à tous les problèmes ça
beaucoup beaucoup de défauts et vous lui
avez très bien ciblé et on reviendra
plus longuement sur cette notion de
socialement aussi alquines définition en
fait très très très compliqué notamment
avec collaboration à venir avec super
philosophe et pour répondre à l patito
feo quelles sont les hypothèses du cadre
dans lequel on définit bcg et bien
l'hypothèse de base c'est que l'utilité
de chacun est une fonction qui s'écrit
comme l'utilité de la décision finale
- les paiements qui seront imposées par
le mécanisme pcg en particulier ça
impose une neutralité au risque qui est
une hypothèse qui est fausse comme tu as
parlé dans l'épisode douce et comme le
fait très bien remarqué corps mag en
particulier ça pose beaucoup de
problèmes quand on a des différences de
richesse entre différents individus
quelques alors utilité pour l'argent ne
sont souvent pas de la même forme un
euro pour un individu beaucoup plus
d'utilité qu'un euro pour irish et tout
ça à voir ne serait qu utile it est
marginale décroissante de l'homme on en
a déjà parlé dans l'épisode tous c'est
bien celui monsieur fille nous demandent
comment doit être répartie l'argent qui
a été collecté par le mécanisme vcg à
travers les paiements des personnes qui
ont influé sur le résultat final
et bien à ce qu'il ya c'est bizarre
c'est en fait ces paiements il faut
absolument les brûler c'est assez
bizarre mais il faut en fait absolument
pas les répartir aux parties prenantes
de la prise de décision parce que sinon
comme le fait très bien remarqué ces
ruines ça peut donner des incentive aux
autres villes d'annoncer des prix qui
sont plus grands que ceux qui sont
vraiment prêts à payer pour donner
l'impression qu'ils sont beaucoup plus
déçu par la présence d'individus qui
donnait l'impression que l'individu
impute un coût social plus élevé aux
autres villes et à ce moment là du coup
elle paiera plus d'argent et plus
d'argent pour être redistribués à tout
le monde et donc la clé très très
importante pour éviter ce genre
d'initiative
c'est de ne pas redistribuer l'argent
qui est qu était super contente ici
c'est super bizarre alors ce qui peut
être fait pour avoir des budgets à peu
près neutre et l'argent ne soit pas
vraiment beau et c'est d'anticiper la
somme qui sera collecté au préalable et
de la prélever donc avant de lancer le
mécanisme vcg comme étant une taxe mais
il faut absolument que cette taxe ne
soit pas une réaction à ce qui a été
révélé ensuite fixé le mécanisme de
grove dont j'avais parlé mais le
problème des mécanismes de grosses en
général c'est qu'ils ne satisfont pas la
rationalité individuel et en particulier
ça ça peut amener à des mouvements
indépendantistes ça ça fait aussi écho à
la question de riquet fac par exemple
dans l'exemple que j'ai donné le petit
village a donné une grande valuation au
réseau routier 1 et douce est vraiment à
cause de ce petit village que la grande
ville doit payer beaucoup d'argent et du
coup quelques choses assez bizarres dans
tout ça en fait la présence du petit
village impute un grand paiement à la
grande ville ça c'est pas du tout pris
en compte dans vcg fait vcg oublié un
peu tout ce qui est paiements tout ce
qui est paiement s'est réglé après et en
particulier en concert que les paiements
non pas un coup sûr l'optimalité sociale
si vous encore une fois une hypothèse
qui est très discutable qui en fait faut
se pratique encore enfin le mec isère
vcg est loin loin loin d'être la réponse
à tous les problèmes mais mois et des
années de recherches montrent que ces
temps facile en tout cas de faire mieux
que le mécanisme
w 14 aces 36 f ils demandent aussi s'il
n'y a pas des risques de corruption en
fait oui parce que lorsqu'on applique le
mutisme vcg il est individuellement une
ces titres compatibles c'est à dire que
sachant ce que les autres font chacun a
tout intérêt à révéler ses vrais
valuation des différentes alternatives
mais en général deux villes ont tout
intérêt à collaborer pour que ensemble
elles deviennent chacune le moins
influent possible sur la décision finale
tout en étant influence with the right
même à faire basculer la balance vers
l'adhésion qu'elles veulent on dit que
le mécanisme vcg et individuellement
initiative combattue ball mais il n'est
pas groupe initiatives comme patti ball
et ça ça fait aussi écho aux questions
de colin roland robert et vince que matt
à kallista surtout le second qui fait la
remarque que si on faisait ça pour tout
la démocratie pour chacun des individus
la démocratie eh bien personne n'aura à
payer quoi que ce soit puisque
individuellement
personne n'a d'influencé sur les
décisions finales et ça ça fait de la
prise de décision à très très très grand
nombre après mme beaucoup plus difficile
en tout cas avec des propriétés assez
différentes des pannes de prise de
décision avec un groupe assez restreint
et on en avait parlé notamment dans
l'épisode 11 où on parlait de la thèse
de brens caplanne qui cependant que ça
ça a conduit beaucoup de gens aillent
voter de façon rationnelle mans
irrationnel bref comme vous voyez
prendre des décisions collectives
globalement c'est super galère j'espère
que vous avez aimé cette vidéo la
prochaine fois on va parler encore un
peu plus du partage de gâteau on va
pouvoir notamment des solutions
procédurales pour découper un gâteau en
pratique ou à peu près en pratique mais
pas forcément en pratique pratique je
suis pas très à l'aise avec l'un plutôt
mais de façon peut être un peu plus
pratique que ceux dont on vient de
parler dans cette vidéo si vous avez
aimez cette vidéo pensez à cliquer
arrêts commentés à la partager pensez à
vous abonner pour ne pas manquer futurs
épisodes merci au super power dont et
j'espère que vous serez là
la prochaine fois il ya quelques règles
qui sont vraiment exactement les mêmes
pour tous mais à en france en tout cas
on a le droit d'exercer des métiers
différents de celui de son voisin la
flèche a forcément le cas ah bon donc
donc tous les temps à partager
guitariste tout le monde est vraiment à
égalité et ça peut pas être un petit peu
trop restrictif dans certains cas assez
peyras notice noël vie il plastique
rythme il ya eu 10 1 300 camions nba
johan à 5,8 me your chair et novès good
as it is not belles heures de michael
owen antonio rubio point de vue marché a
perdu recherche des records we are in
different